a few steps away from the outer Triomphe
Chinese lion statues got the entrance of
the new Peninsula Paris the Hong Kong
and Shanghai hotels along with Qatar
spent more than 1 billion dollars to
acquire and restore the building where
Kissinger signed the end of the Vietnam
War
we took this venerable building
maintained it with 2,500 beams whilst
digging underneath the structure three
levels of parking
inside you'll find crystal leaves
hanging down the lobby six restaurants
including a panoramic one on the top
floor and high in Chinese cuisine on the
ground floor the spa with an indoor
swimming pool and 200 rooms with marble
bathrooms and iPads to control
everything in the room prices start at
$900 a night up to nearly $35,000 for
the most expensive Street Paris enjoys
very high room rates compared to
international standards clearly we want
to be at the top of the Paris market but
the competition will be fierce
they are already more than 50 luxury
five-star hotels in Paris some
undergoing refurbishment Mohamed
al-fayed is spending nearly 200 million
dollars to renovate the Ritz the Saudi
royal family almost as much on the
Korean so with so much new offer will
prices fall I don't think prices will go
down and York and London have many more
what does at that category than Paris
which means that there's still room for
another four or five potential hotels of
that level in the next years with a
replica biplane on its roof the company
says it wants the peninsula to be a new
landmark of Paris but in this city it
won't be short of competition